huit jours après tt fiançailles avec
suzy tu apprends qu elle et qu'elle est
malade cardiaque et comme elle savait
que tu voulais avoir des enfants elle te
dit non nous nous marions pas et ça tu
l'a épousée quand même oui je l'épousé
puis je le fais des enfants ouais c'est
ça j'ai pris des risques dlc les devil
salif sy si elle avait un courage
fabuleux et d'ailleurs suzie a subi
trois opérations à coeur ouvert et son
médecin m'avait dit que je pouvais avoir
seulement un enfant et puis bon j'ai eu
d'aussi à et quand elle a après
cinq ans après elle était enceinte de
jean-claude mais entre temps elle a eu
d'autres grossesses qu'on était obligé
de
faire partir parce que parce que c'était
très très dangereux pour sa santé risque
est carrément sa vie malgré ces
religieuses ah oui non mais là non dans
notre religion il ya quelque chose de
fantastique quand la santé est en jeu il
n'ya plus les mêmes lois religieusement
les personnes en danger quand ils sont
malades ou par exemple le samedi si on
n'a pas le droit d'allumer le feu ou
deux si c'est pour éclairer la chambre
d'un malade pour lui venir en rond là on
peut on doit même tout de même interdit
de ne pas le faire si mal interdit de ne
pas le faire l'amour que tu lui
apportait était sans doute aussi un
remède est ce que tu crois que l'humour
peut être un remède ah ben oui l'humour
c'est d'abord les gens qui n'ont pas
d'humour pour moi
ce qui leur manque une case c'est sur
cure c'est pour ça que les comiques ont
une valeur spirituelle très importante
c'est plus important de faire rire même
que d'émouvoir